hey guys it is the 12th of January today
my name is jess mcdonald and i'm back
with your daily dose of gamespot news
let's see what happened today Platinum
Games with upcoming Xbox one exclusive
scalebound is gonna be really great
according to the people who are
publishing scalebound the new title from
the developers of bayonetta 2 and metal
gear rising revengeance has earned the
praise of marks of creative director can
log Club hasn't fleshed out exactly what
will be getting with scalebound but said
that platinum are building the kind of
game they do well and microsoft to
adding on what they do well other than
that were being promised dragons dragon
companions as an experience that will
shock gamers he explains quote
scalebound is very real and very awesome
and i think when people really
understand what it is we are building
they're going to be shocked it's
definitely big Lane for those of you who
are keen to crack into for V wants you
to evolve on your PC the system
requirements have been revealed today
the very reasonable minimum specs call
for one gigabyte of video memory in each
geforce gtx 560 or radeon HD 5770 video
card 4 gigabytes of system ram and the
core 2 duo e6600 intel cpu or athlon 64
x2 6400 AMD cpu if you want to kick it
up a notch the recommended settings call
for a core i7 920 intel cpu 08 3870 k
AMD cpu along with six gigabytes of
system ram and a geforce gtx 670 or
radeon r9 288 e I video card with two
gigabytes of video memory four sets of
requirements call for windows 7 64 bit
operating system and 50 gigabytes of
hard drive space above is due out
februari 10 after being delayed last
year Microsoft Studios creative director
can love have more stuff to say today
which included teasing the resurrection
of class
references like a banjo kazooie and
perfect dark speaking on the inner
circle podcast blob said will there ever
be another banjo viva pinata blast corps
battletoads yes someday and I think the
reason you see things like the
Battletoads trademark revived is because
we know this value he hasn't made any
promises however and explain I think the
best message to give your listeners is
we love the old IP as much as you do
please be patient because we can only
build so much at a time Bob confirmed
that the rare studio in the UK is not
presently working on a new perfect dark
game let me know down in that comment
box which classic rare franchise you'd
most like to see revived you can also
head to gamestop some more news stories
on things like uncharted for being the
ultimate uncharted and middle gear solid
5 going first person that is it for me
today thanks for sticking around to be
sure to leave me your word pictures in
that comment box and I will catch you
tomorrow